I think part of this instinct to blame
this on man-made climate change firstly
it's very convenient because you get to
blame it on your political opposition if
you're on the left like literally
everything is the fault of conservatives
you go outside and you don't like the
weather it's like well this is some
Republican politician's fault surely it
reminds me of a quote from the one and
only Thomas Soul he said
you know good things just happen and bad
things are somebody's fault that is
exactly how we think that is just our
default pattern and so something like
the weather right is something like New
York being covered in this smog and it
traveling across the country well that
has to be somebody's fault like bad
things can't just happen or things that
bother me can't just happen I have to be
able to blame someone even in the Bible
it's the flood they said that God sent
the flood like why can't we just accept
that it could have just happened why
don't we have to blame since he sent it
I guess we have to blame God for this
one somebody had to do it I mean look I
live in Florida and they try to tell you
hurricanes are man-made I mean like the
Hurricanes never happened before the
Industrial Revolution it's bizarre